[Aplausos]
buenas noches
pues está padrísimo estar aquí con
ustedes
para hablar de las cosas que me gustan
de las cosas que me apasionan y me
encanta hablar de emprender
y a los emprendedores ya los
emprendedores sociales normalmente nos
preguntan cómo lo hicimos y esto es
cuando hablo de emprendimiento lo
primero que me gusta con es que
emprender no se trata sólo de hacer
negocios o de hacer empresas emprender
se trata fundamentalmente de tomar
decisiones de vida y asumir con
responsabilidad lo que implican esas
decisiones
miren emprender también es tomar la
decisión de tener una familia emprender
es decidir conscientemente que queremos
tener un hijo y que lo vamos a formar y
lo que eso implica emprender significa
decidir qué quieres estudiar una carrera
que quiere ser un buen estudiante y
emprender por supuesto también tiene que
ver con arrancar proyectos y cuando uno
decidió emprender la primera cosa que
tienen que saber es que no es glamuroso
que no es una historia de éxito rosa en
la que la gente se para que enfrente a
decir que es súper inteligente y súper
talentoso y entonces la hizo a la
primera y le atinó eso no es real
emprender es trabajar duro cuando les
pregunto a los jóvenes a mis estudiantes
por qué quieren emprender la mayoría de
las respuestas tienen que ver con no
quiero tener un jefe
o quiero ser el dueño de mi tiempo
quiero ser famoso quiero tener mucho
dinero
y los que hemos emprendido sabemos que
emprender primero se trata de entrarle
con todo de trabajar duro que no tienes
un jefe tienes muchos tienes tus
clientes tus colaboradores los
proveedores el pago de impuestos todos
son tus jefes
si eres dueño de tu agenda porque
trabajas 24/7 y los emprendedores
normalmente soñamos con nuestra empresa
y con el otro día y con lo que no hemos
podido hacer y se nos ocurren ideas a
las 3 de la mañana y ojalá que hasta
ahora tengamos una libreta para apuntar
porque en la mañana cuando nos estamos
bañando decimos que fue lo que se me
ocurrió ayer era buena idea con eso lo
resolvía así que emprender se trata de
verdad de entregarse con amor con
entusiasmo con energía a eso que
decidimos hacer
emprender también se trata de hacer
equipo porque nadie lo hace solo el que
venga y se pare aquí enfrente y diga que
él pudo o que ella pudo porque es muy
capaz y porque es muy valiente y porque
le entendió y porque entendió el secreto
del hilo negro la neta es que no sé
igual y si quién sabe
pero yo he aprendido que emprender nunca
se hace solo que se hace con un equipo
con tus socios o con tus colaboradores
con la gente que empieza a creer en ti y
que es absolutamente necesaria para que
después poco a poco con muchos años con
mucho esfuerzo puedas escribir una
historia de éxito
y para construir equipos también he
aprendido algo que les quiero compartir
construir equipos se trata de buscar
gente que crea en lo que tú crees
y para encontrar gente que crea lo que
tú crees es necesario ser claro y
honesto en declarar las cosas en las que
uno cree y entonces así el otro tiene la
posibilidad de decidir genuinamente si
se quiere unir a eso que nosotros
queremos hacer
emprender y hacer equipo también se
trata de convertirse en un líder
congruente porque es muy complicado
pararse en el escenario a dar un
discurso cuando el discurso que ocurre
en el trabajo es otro hay muchas
compañías que tienen hermosos cuadros a
la entrada de sus oficinas esos que
hablan de la misión de la visión de los
valores pero que adentro adentro viven
otras realidades así que para hacer
equipo es absolutamente necesario ser
congruentes pero emprender tiene un
componente que tal vez lo hace más
especial que todo lo demás y emprender
de verdad se trata de encontrar tu
pasión
y la pasión no es otra cosa que eso que
tenemos tatuado en la piel eso que
podríamos hacer aunque no nos paguen es
más eso que podríamos hacer aunque nos
toque pagar
y si logramos encontrar eso que nos
apasiona eso que nos emociona entonces
saben que dediquen el resto de su vida a
eso no lo inventé no le busquen a otra
cosa porque cuando uno de verdad se
dedica a esto que lo emociona a eso que
lo hace sentir vivo las cosas fluyan las
cosas pasan distinto y yo les tengo que
presumir que encontré muy temprano en la
vida lo que me apasionaba y entonces el
resto solo ha sido dejar que fluya
dedicarme con el corazón con el alma a
eso que decidí que mi vida tenía como
misión y saben que también he
descubierto que hay misiones que son
superiores a tu voluntad hay misiones
que son tu destino y cuando defines
dedicar con emoción y con amor
la vida a este destino entonces las
cosas funcionan mejor y entonces
descubrí les decía que mi pasión es la
salud
y el sector salud porque todavía tenemos
una salud que en realidad es un derecho
limitado y es un derecho que está
limitado al tipo de relación laboral que
tienen las personas porque tengo derecho
a un servicio de salud si soy empleado y
un derecho a un servicio de salud si soy
desempleado y tengo derecho a un
servicio de salud mejor si tengo un
mejor nivel socioeconómico y tengo
derecho a lo que haya si tengo un bajo
nivel socioeconómico y lo más complicado
no es eso lo más complicado es contarles
que solamente el 5% de la población en
el mundo tiene verdadero acceso a la
salud es decir tiene verdadero acceso a
todo lo que necesite para conservar su
vida o para tratar una enfermedad todos
los demás más del 90% de la población en
el mundo se convierten en pacientes de
segunda de tercera de cuarta o de quinta
y en los pacientes de quinta están todas
esas personas con enfermedades complejas
cuya única opción es esperar el día de
su muerte y suena muy dramático lo que
les estoy contando pero mientras de los
cuentos se me ocurren los pacientes con
ciertos tipos de cáncer que aún no son
cubiertos por el sistema de salud y
entonces ante un diagnóstico en serio lo
único que están esperando es el día de
su muerte y entonces a mí se me antojó
que mi vida se podría dedicar a eso que
mi día y mi vida se podía dedicar
a buscar soluciones para que la gente
pueda tener mejor acceso y mejor derecho
a la salud y además porque tenemos un
problema muy complicado es este una
tendencia epidemiológica global que es
eso que nos estamos enfermando de cosas
más complicadas
le escuché decir a alguien el otro día
que estamos en una fila de la que
ninguno se puede escapar y esa fila se
llama envejecimiento
unos más adelante unos más atrás pero
todos estamos en esa fila
irremediablemente y con el
envejecimiento más del 65% de esta
población tiene una enfermedad
crónico-degenerativa
hoy vemos cómo tenemos un diagnóstico de
enfermedades complejas como el cáncer de
mama en pacientes realmente muy jóvenes
pacientes de 25 o 27 años hoy tienen que
enfrentar estos padecimientos y el
diagnóstico es creciente
casi todos hoy tenemos una historia
personal o muy muy cercana con una de
estas enfermedades he aprendido que el
diagnóstico no lo recibe solo el
paciente así que no se trata solo de
medicinas y cirugías el diagnóstico lo
recibe su pareja sus hijos su economía
su trabajo y por supuesto el sistema de
salud entonces el impacto que estas
enfermedades tienen en la sociedad es
mucho más grande
hay un problema más grave aún
y es que no pensamos en la salud hasta
que necesitamos un hospital hasta que
estamos enfermos no pensamos en la salud
hasta que tenemos un problema que nos
dice
y si yo me hubiera cuidado más
no pensamos en la salud hasta que
tenemos la necesidad de enfrentar uno de
estos retos y entonces con todo esto en
mente
creamos una empresa que desarrolló un
modelo que defiende que todos estos
pacientes con enfermedades complejas con
enfermedades graves
necesitan medicina personalizada y la
medicina personalizada no es otra cosa
que entender que un paciente no es un
número de expediente que a un paciente
no es un diagnóstico un paciente es un
ser humano como cualquiera de nosotros
que además de todos los retos de todas
las frustraciones de todas las
necesidades tiene además que enfrentarse
al dolor de una enfermedad como el
cáncer o como la esclerosis múltiple o
como la artritis reumatoide o como la
insuficiencia renal crónica muchas de
estas enfermedades ni siquiera tienen
cura pero el paciente puede vivir muchos
años con ella
a medida que avanza la enfermedad se van
deteriorando sus condiciones y su
calidad de vida y entonces va a requerir
aún mayor atención para cuidarse y
entonces hace nueve años fundé en méxico
una empresa que se llama psoe y que se
dedica a acompañar esos pacientes no
semos autodenominado el ángel guardián y
lo que hacemos es acompañar gestionar
asesorar cuidar ayudarle a la familia
y darle información relevante a los
médicos tratantes que entre otras cosas
tienen que ver por ejemplo con la
expresión genética de los tumores de los
pacientes que le permite a los médicos
de identificar tratamientos
individualizados y entonces mejorar la
probabilidad de éxito de esos mismos
tratamientos que además son
altísimamente costosos pero para
explicarles cuál es el impacto que tiene
este servicio déjenme contarles una
historia es la historia de doña anna un
día iba yo entrando al centro de
atención telefónica donde están todos
los conciertos hablando con los
pacientes y entonces una de nuestras
conciertos susana estaba explicándole a
una paciente cómo hacer un pay de limón
y tardo mucho tiempo creo que fue una
llamada de media hora claramente no
somos un call center
cuando termino le dije oye susana no
sabía que teníamos un programa de cocina
en una licencia este déjeme contarle
doña anna es una paciente que tiene
cáncer de pulmón metastásico cáncer
avanzado y ella lleva dos semanas sin
levantarse de su cama está muy deprimida
se siente mal entonces yo le llamo todas
las mañanas y platico con ella un rato
de la habilidad cómo se siente hablamos
de cualquier cosa y esta mañana la llamé
y me dijo que anoche había soñado
haciendo un país de limón y que hoy sí
tenía ganas de levantarse así que le
dije muy bien usted se va a levantar se
va a bañar se va a poner guapa y yo
mientras tanto le voy a investigar cómo
se hace el país de limón porque doñana
no tenía ni idea
le ayude a pedir los ingredientes que
faltaban para que los llevaran a su casa
y así que en este momento que ya
llegaron le estaba explicando cómo hacer
el pay de limón doñana murió tres meses
después
cuando un paciente fallece hablamos con
la familia y le ofrecemos algunas
sesiones adicionales para enfrentar este
proceso de duelo así que una de las
psicólogas la psicóloga que atendía a
doñana habló con sus hijos para
presentarle condolencias y ofrecerle
este apoyo los hijos que vivían fuera
del país
doñana biblia sola explicado que no era
necesario que estaban preparados porque
sabían que la enfermedad de su madre era
muy grave pero que tenían una pregunta
entonces su hijo le dice a ver usted es
la psicóloga de mi mamá si sé si le
puedo hacer una pregunta mis tías decían
que mi mamá estaba empezando a tener
demencia senil porque tenía una amiga
imaginaria una tal susana y hablaba todo
el tiempo de hecho soy la psicóloga le
dice no no no era una amiga imaginaria
era su concierto los hijos fueron a la
oficina a conocer a susana a tomarse
fotos con ella ya contarle que ella
había hecho que los últimos meses de
vida
fueran diferentes tenía una historia
nueva tenía una persona que le hablaba
que se interesaba que le ayudaba y se
había convertido en su mejor amiga de
eso se trata lo que hacemos de acompañar
de contarle a la gente que vale la pena
apasionarse por la vida miren los seres
humanos somos tan complejos que
solamente valoramos la vida cuando
tenemos enfrente la inminencia de la
muerte ahí nos acordamos ahí nos
acordamos que lo más importante es estar
vivos y les dejo una frase de un
paciente que salude el otro día en el
corredor de mi oficina dijo hola cómo
estás
iván qué gusto verte iván tiene un
cáncer de pulmón complicado y la
quimioterapia hizo que perdiera la
motricidad fina movimiento de sus manos
esto no sería tan grave si además iván
no fuera músico y entonces la
quimioterapia hizo que ya no pueda tocar
su instrumento
y me contesta iván como estoy vivo
que es muy buena noticia así que estoy
muy vivo y muy contento cómo estás tú y
yo les pregunto a ustedes cómo están
ustedes porque estamos vivos con ganas y
con la oportunidad de emprender y de
hacer de este mundo un lugar mejor de
contarle a los demás que cuando se vayan
porque todos nos vamos a morir dejaron
huella valió la pena hicieron una
diferencia quieren emprender háganlo en
algo que cambien la realidad quieren
emprender en salud sientes en un
hospital público una mañana se les van a
ocurrir muchas ideas en educación
bájense una escuela pública de que
quieren de primaria de secundaria oa una
universidad en transporte usen el
transporte público se les van a ocurrir
muchas ideas vivimos en países en donde
hay muchos problemas y muchas
necesidades conviertan las en
oportunidades
que pueden ser motores de transformación
social crean que vale la pena
apasionarse por la vida y si hoy estamos
vivos y seguramente mañana también que
valga la pena levantarse y que cuando
regresen a su casa a verse en el espejo
o el de cristal o el de sus seres
queridos puedan estar absolutamente
orgullosos porque dejaron en ese día lo
mejor de ustedes muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]